what's happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alva and I'm John we're going to watch
the trailer today for mine hunter good
here we go the Netflix series a lot of
requests have come in so you can Oh
which you can follow some the TV time
app that we actually use you guys that
TV time app is great we update every
time we watch an episode of something
because we don't always shoot for
reviews of the shows but if you want to
keep updated with us on what we're
updating on check out well you gonna
stir come on
it's not easy butchering people so work
physically and mentally I don't think
people realize we need to then yeah you
know there's a lot more like me do you
think so
40 years ago your FBI was founded
hunting down John Dillinger now we have
extreme violence between strangers we
travel around the country and teach FBI
techniques to cops you guys notify Bobby
forget it
she was filed cost and lives to the dead
people won't do to each other there's
some people wanted okay now we should be
using every resource again talking the
smartest people we find from the
broadest possible spectrum are criminals
born into your correctness or are they
form psychopaths and convinced there's
nothing wrong with them so these men is
virtually impossible to study that you
found a way in near perfect laboratory
conditions hello ladies that's what
makes it so exciting
potentially so far-reaching guys are
above me
thank you any of you sex in claiming it
is not our job to commiserate with these
people it is our job to electrocute them
can't like everything we do we're
talking to serial killers serial killers
the terminology
control each reward you Wow to just
going to bite you in the ass for me to
be ruining people's wallets and you do
you're developing a pattern of behavior
that will not sustain you here Haeju for
if you leave I can't hold it there's no
procedural rule book for how to talk to
these people if any of this is going to
work we need to pass some more some more
truffles you've got to get in the dirt
with the pigs
whoa
how do we get ahead of crazy if we don't
know how crazy things that looks amazing
I am so stoked to see that and I feel
like David Fincher shot it doesn't
working on something new that involves
serial killers looks like shot and
edited exactly like a David Fincher
movie yeah oh my gosh I totally called
it I really had no idea
holy crap yeah that looks amazing and I
love David Fincher's films that is
easily one of my favorite directors
because he is only directed three
episodes but in terms of just a subject
matter of the FBI coming in and in the
new term of serial killers I grew up
fascinated by serial killers I would
read about Charles Manson I would read
about richard kuklinski doesn't like the
too many people read about used to be
addicted to the show i watch on Netflix
called serial killer couples so to see
like when the government and the FBI
became aware of this type of murderer
this type of killer because it has a
psychological study and this is super
Fincher like in terms of this person who
has a job has to do something has to
learn a lot more in order to prevent
these crimes or stop criminals but the
more he gets involved in understanding
it the bigger deterioration it takes on
his own soul and well-being it's pure
venture to me is look amazing I cannot
wait to watch this show yeah this looks
really cool and I like the the hint of
the scope anyway you know because true
crime is is such a popular thing that
people go nuts with your crime their
shows and podcasts and books and you
know blogs and everything you can think
of it and I like that they're
approaching this sort of from the
procedural side in a different way than
just focusing on one case it's like yeah
we're learning about this whole section
of society and we're training each other
how to deal with it and some people are
on board with that some people are I
like this sort of early procedure
idea that they're going for and also
just generally speaking true crying I
had to read a lot of it for work and
true time is one of the harder things
for me to take a lot in because uh you
know true-crime yeah I was usually
grizzly and it's usually unsettling and
if there's anything I know about David
Fincher he's good at this kind of oh yes
seven zodiac yeah the countless tipping
but for you and he's listed all to the
executor all attendees episode so I know
he's got to have you know pretty big
hand on this and yeah this looks really
intriguing and I hope it turns out well
because to get this expansive about the
FBI and about you know just the way we
approach serial killers from a law
enforcement perspective is a pretty
fascinating feels unsettling it feels
fascinating too and I know this is an
October release and it doesn't it's not
exactly horror but then again like even
Fincher terrific it's horrific in its
own way it's like when you were looking
at true crime articles for your horror
site yes for a horror side and then here
true crime it's terrific and not what
you think about with horror movies but
there's certainly a horror element to it
that's something David Richard is very
well to is he provides horror elements
in films and stories when you wouldn't
walk in thinking you're going to watch a
horror film you know I think it would be
a great show to binge watching the month
of October for sure oh yeah definitely
especially if you want to get dark yeah
alright guys so thanks for sending that
our way that was really freaking cool
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click the notification bell - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and
check out our patreon for exclusive
perks and rewards a lot of fun goodies
starting ages one